la première pour qui c'est très très
gentil pour commencer mais l'on sait sur
bergerac a tracé guillaume genton qui
nous le dit à benjamin castaldi à une
habitude très gênante il va
régulièrement péter dans la loge des
invités avant qu'ils n'arrivent
elles franchement castanet si si c'est
faux mais alors la sanction plus quoi
inventer au détriment voyez franchement
me déplacer qu'ils allaient faire un
petit pet ou dans les habitations
arrêtez vous au précédent mais c'est une
armée de façon qu'on n'est pas là pour
dire c'est bruce et pour la banque c'est
vrai mais moi je sais que c'est vrai
peut dire on peut dire tout et n'importe
quoi des frères allons-y arrêté c'est
vrai mais castaldi arrêté arrêté
d'augmenter par ses montagnes pas oui ah
merde qu'un but casey barbosa ah oui
c'est quoi ce nul fauchon un rendez vous
très important cyril a piqué les
macarons qui étaient sur la table les a
plantés dans un mouchoir qui est parti
comme un voleur
s'est implanté au canada ou alors
c'était à je vous le dis c'était une
réunion pour voir avec les actionnaires
et j'aimerais que voilà il y avait des
macarons mais pour moi j'ai tout de
suite
ah ouais ils sont partis avec voilà tout
simplement pour les donner à mes équipes
les enfants tant reçu on peut demander à
mes vous n'êtes pas les équipes je parle
mais équipe avec moi oui et c'est à dire
que là par exemple s'ils ont demandé aux
équipes elles confirmeraient bien sûr
d'accord on peut appeler ça une quatre
ans par exemple n'ont
pas dû partir de ce qu'il montre toi de
macarons ils ne mangent pas de tout du
cycle de sucré avec un diabétique
les chéris au
décor alors là non ça va trop loin quoi
là les mecs cette peau qui sur qui est
source d'un chroniqueur anonyme ok ça là
bas raymond olabe alors là et c'est vrai
je me cachais vous
évoquez dit
non je pense vous savez quand il ya une
peau qui est que la personne dise où là
je ne cache
généralement c'est que c'est pas loin
c'est violent j'attends de savoir ce que
ça va être quoi ya de la musique violon
assez violent mais cette violence vienne
le torchon brûle entre raymond isabelle
à tel point que raymond a déjà dit si un
jour j'ai arrêté pmp ce sera à cause d'
isabelle
on arrête avec les pays bas car bon
[Rires]
ça y est on à pétion nama carreau dès
maintenant bon alors c'est bon vraiment
quelque chose j'aimerais vraiment
qu'isabelle et toi ça mais ça je n'ai
jamais dit ça d'accord bon bah très bien
donc je rassure et ça c'est vrai ça
rouille et donc je vous crois que la
tombe voilà c'est vrai que je sais qu
isabelle et toi c'est pas du tout ils
sont je pense pas que soyons guerre moi
non alors on peut le dire ils sont pas
pas du tout merci 20
excusez-moi
parlement voilà des différences sur
plein de sujets et parfois ça monte en
pression j'ai déchaussé l'émission si sa
ket quoi j'ai pas de s'apprécier non
mais ça lui est d'accord et ça va voilà
vous
est-ce que c'est sur le bon chemin le
chemin quel chemin le chemin de la tête
fréquentiel et sont de 2,2 de l'amitié
kapadia pas de blessure c'est
sa place à tpm paix et vous aussi pas
que ceux-ci et moi moi je suis je vous
dis je suis là en interne intermittents
du spectacle en gîte en jeu n'a pas
l'air bien
ils avaient tous les deux et je sais que
ça va en plus cette côte à côte
peut-être content d'être un de vous voir
quand même
pas du tout
dire il ya besoin à chaque fois d'être
assurée il n'y a pas de je suis assez
bon j'aime être assurés que tu me
demandes si
j'aime bien quand on sent déjà mieux
qu'en france entend bien que quand tu y
es la merde maintenant si tu nous lis
tout à l'heure un truc qu'on va se
refera casser ce sera un castrat c'est
pas la wii c'est pendant que ce sac est
ok
mais beaucoup quand il était là je
l'aimais
j'ai beaucoup aimé bien quand j'étais
jeune gens et vous adore était un petit
bijou fait mon petit bisou bisou
[Applaudissements]
d'être content là vous avez à prendre
une très bonne nouvelle ah ouais les
primes ont été validés non non non non
vous avez un système à paddle demain ça
lui cyril way rendez vous à 13h30 pour
samedi au p 500 de marville pour la
paddle
je vais peut-être de séries tu es
directement en huitièmes de finale
[Applaudissements]
le rib est bien arrivé
à
valérie bénaïm écrire et dans le plus
grand secret et ce depuis la saison
dernière un brûlot sur les coulisses de
tp
non mais un brûlot c'est comme laure
brunet à celles qui provoquent l'arrêt
mais non mais c'est quoi cette histoire
bah c'est vrai
c'est pas un brûlot raconte touche
balance
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
écrit un livre effectivement qui sortira
en janvier mais qui n'a absolument rien
à voir avec tpm chaud si ça n'a rien à
voir rien à voir me dis tiens vous dites
magie c'est tout bête mais lindsay lohan
a durant l'année vous avez tous eu la
trouille
qui sont à dire sur vous nommer sans
rigoler mais voilà alors les chiroux dit
déjà tout issia
castaldi s'est fait surprendre plusieurs
fois faire les poches des chroniqueurs
dans les loges pour se payer des cafés
castanet vous êtes un personnage
horrible c'est horrible
c
ces trois volets cette poule j ai
complètement naze non marrakech jamais
dit aux gens ton sur les témoignages les
chroniqueurs faites bien attention à vos
poches
semaine dernière j'avais une veste
pailletée j'avais deux billets de 10
euros et j'ai vu l'ignoble castaldi mais
les prendre
devant les yeux dans les yeux l'argent
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes tombé à ba et met ses yeux
j'entends
me fait marcher immédiatement merci s'il
vous plaît à la wii un ballet les
dociles à ce qu'on aurait pu mener vos
menaces alors ses misères ce
soit guillaume genton j'ai indiqué
raymond un match du plj il a passé plus
de temps à chiner madoff qu'à regarder
les
gens vous croit totalement dépassés
mardi soir aux dommages du ps ouais et
j'ai invité des amis vraiment je croyais
que c'était mon ami es une fille que
j'aimais bien et en fait au fil du match
je me suis rendu compte que dès que
j'avais le dos tourné l'abominable
bourgi
[Rires]
tu veux conduire à mon camion
le présenter ces faits ça ignoble c'est
magnifique véridique bah bravo bravo à
vous c'est alors sa belle en catastrophe
alors il est arrivé parce qu'il faisait
des missions qu'il arrivait à 21h30 et
là bas il a fait se déplacer tout le
monde juge n'a ni par action moi je me
suis dit je suis content mais regarder
un match de foot ensemble au final
qu'est ce qui se passe à la mi temps il
me dit descatoire mon ami havas m du
coup je me décale d'un siège et un mec
qui vient à côté des cartes war mon
programme ce matin j'ai fini j'ai failli
finir le match car les bus
un match au milieu de terrain petit à
petit chenal des gaffes de l'état
l'autre bouger mais si je regarde pas le
match avec mu enfin avec qui fait quand
même j'ai kiffé quand même et je vais
revoir sa copie
pour s'assurer mantois badr est un bon
ami de curling de place c'est un
passionné
de foot mais oui alors oui
ça ne pouvait pas me citer qu'elles cinq
jours du psg moi je bats toi si tu es
saadi
moi je vois que
c'est moral et merci valérie bénaïm
alors vous les donnez là pou qui parce
que c'est tout à fait vous allez vous
démerder que moi je resterai bah oui
parce qu'il me met comme témoin mais mes
jeux je valide tout à fait ce qu'il voit
l'histoire alors de cyril a tellement
peur des microbes que quand ils se
baignent dans une piscine il demande à
tout le monde d'en sortir ou alors de
prendre une douche à la bêta d'ie9
pas s'il
est ce qu'on vous êtes malade est ce que
ray les yeux dans les yeux c'est la
remarque est ce que quand vous êtes dans
une piscine d'autres personnes en droit
d'y être en bons plans des gens tant la
faute la nation alors voilà leguillaume
bas si j étais avec cyril et personne
n'a été désinfectés voilà exactement
merci et pourquoi tu ne vois pas du tout
où on a des photos ville comme devant
des photos des urnes il est vrai mais
c'est la vraie c'est la vérité c'est la
vérité c'est juste une question de
confiance
juste une question de confiance à la
libé novelli est la vérité dit la vérité
dit la vérité quelli
che non mais j'ai trop la pression
eh bien
[Applaudissements]
non mais vous devez la vérité est ce que
je suis forte sur tout le monde vous
avez vraiment de doute gros travers
psychologique si
vous passez le petit c'est tout ça c'est
vrai et puis on avait peur alors qu'on
est encore dans voilà encore vides oui
moi j'applaudis je respecte les gestes
barrière pan peuvent se baigner dans la
piscine tous mes copains oui
le
fait que vous ayez à la piscine
municipale de boulogne
on parle de bâtons et de barres et un
maillot et on parle on parle de vacances
des vacances cet été la suisse est bénie
avec moi moi tu es là tu sais de quel
pays ouais c'est une privé auquel maison
mais pas du tout j'avais j'ai eu la
chance on avait une maison avec mme
guillaume dans le sud oui oui
j'avais loué une maison ensemble à deux
dans le sud oui
les bases et aux vacances ensemble c'est
cela ou qui n'ont à ce que vous saviez
pas mais non non non
on n'irait pas quoi vous payer à 50 50
alors comme pour la coordination
ses 50 ans en fait on était voisins à la
maison non chaque nom mais moi j'ai
envoyé des maisons - nicox non mais pas
du tout
je me suis jamais caché c'est vrai que
voilà g il n'y a pas de mer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que j'ai un petit
pied-à-terre dans le sud je me suis
jamais caché dania élus avaient loué une
maison juste à côté de moi
comme un pied-à-terre ou alors tombé
qu'utaka et lobbies alliez chez l'un
chez l'autre north mois il venait chez
moi je suis jamais de l hépatite
la piscine était chez vous non qu'il
allait dans le sénateur oui dans le pet
à terre alors d'accord d'accord
comme jacuzzi aussi c'était chez vous
alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a fait pour moi non et jacuzzi
[Rires]
2e donc et dans la piscine on peut être
combien à la
[Rires]
3'
pied-à-terre voit la foule ni guillaume
s'il te plaît tu peux dire à tes amis la
merde en fait beaucoup de fans alors je
suis dans aucune alors vraiment c'était
avec ses bons et on était dans le
jacuzzi tous les deux ouais on à
échanger autour de la grille de ces 8es
quand exactement jouent alors c'est vrai
tout ça dans le
studio la petite studette oui mais voilà
il un jacuzzi voilà un match et ça fait
quand même deux mètres carrés un
pied-à-terre
certainement un sérieux manque un
je ne sais plus quoi j'ai rien dit et la
fin
matthieu delormeau a expliqué dans la
presse que s'il avait quitté tmp c'était
pour se lancer sur scène et au cinéma
vient nous dire dans combien de civils
[Applaudissements]
cette attaque a su dompter dakar
alors alors extraordinaire magnifique
ses autres alors revenons ce
pied-à-terre non non mais n'égale
qu'ovide bah oui il peut vite ça va
bloquer tout a débloqué le cinéma
j'avais des propositions
il y avait des projets de cinéma c'était
bloqué qu'ovide la mecque qui j'ai passé
mon année quoi qu'est ce que tu as toi
je te tends même toit a pas de quoi
qu'est ce que tu dis
quoi
moi je dis tout arrête pas de me montrer
benjamin castaldi qu'est ce qui se passe
mais bon
j'avais vraiment trop de tensions
sociales
s'expriment il ya une boutique sur
lequel paupières et les boucles gens
réunis là sur benjamin castaldi a
demandé un graphiste de l'émission
d'augmenter la taille de son anatomie de
son pénis surtout lui
[Applaudissements]
la source et le rapide mais c'est bon
je savais la mairie et la microfaune il
est à la limite d'un vagin
non mais c'est vrai que non mais c'est
vrai ce qu'il soit et c'est là la source
était le graphiste oui c'est vrai ça il
a demandé à regarder ça c'était ça la
bresse et
si je peux me permettre vous avez une
très belle tchèque
[Applaudissements]
cherry a sur ce matthieu delormeau voilà
à isabelle morini-bosc aurait des dons
des compute 1 à l'aréna coiffer l'oeil
de verre la paix rue et non mais non
elles sont à moi qu'à
alors tient à bois benjamin qui est bel
et bien d'autres sur ce bateau que moi
antoine c'est une peau qui sur moi
estimant qu'il ne gagne pas assez
d'argent cyril hanouna joue fréquemment
aux jeux à gratter une photo d'ailleurs
fabriqué ben hameda l'or alors regardez
servait
de bacon et toutes baissé pour le
pied-à-terre
vous avez pas honte
attendez quoi c'est sûr que c'est ça
votre boutique qu'est ce qui rend
hommage à mme à castres benjamin
castaldi à la gastro depuis une semaine
d'un spa moi et ne m'a informé personne
ils avaient trop peur de perdre des
piges à ça alors donné à mathieu ces
prêts devraient être épargnés c'est vrai
ça fait peur d'abord d'abord je devais
pas la gastro j'avais j'ai mangé du thon
avariée
empoisonné c'est pour ça je me suis vidé
pendant deux jours derrière
moi si j'étais malade et moi donc je
n'ai effectivement pas nar
on les connaît mais comme on est rien
[Applaudissements]
beyeler j'irai faire un tour l'une ya eu
un rapprochement entre eryl prayer et
isabelle en loge à isabelle isabelle
s'est assise sur ses genoux et le
chanteur aurait tenté de lui chanter
love me tender bah oui c'est vrai que la
partition il m'a demandé gentiment
demain soir sur ses genoux je suis bien
élevé je me suis assise sur ses genoux
au maire de refuser un accord
tâtonnements l'intrus goodyear
non quand même pas dire non à dire non
mais vous l'aimez bien vous voulez mais
bien bas 11e médaille est très sympa
même quand il chante et tarija santé
c'est papa qui dit ça ici c'est chez
vous il venait couper un truc lycées
castaldi de caste à liessies
régulièrement de gratter des cadeaux
service partenariat consoles jeux vidéo
et même des fleurs pour sa femme le jour
de la saint valentin
[Musique]
mais c'est jen d'acquis et de dire ça
non c'est jean da des charges end à jean
d'amanda et effectivement c'est vrai que
quand il est de coutume que genband
s'est parlé on n'avait pas un deuxième
voilà c'est vrai que pour la saint
valentin n'est pas tant la chesnaie faut
que je travaille beaucoup j'étais sur le
plateau et j'ai pris des flops était
trop tard livrer des fleurs la wii vous
êtes extrêmement sympa au
gabon rose
matthieu delormeau et guillaume genton
ne se lasse jamais les mains après être
allés aux sanitaires en dépit des règles
d'hygiène de base sa mère jeanney c'est
complètement faux non ça c'est les
équipes jouent nous le dit notre
tiens
tiens tiens ça n'est rien n'est jamais
sûr vous dis heureusement il y en a eu
plein sonar du produit cité d'abord
échappe à laquelle si c'est la quête sur
benjamin castaldi
c'est une williams photo à l'appui hier
sur laquelle tu es belle la régie vous
pouvez dire dans l'oreille de cire et la
construction
merci dit moi le dernier repos qui sur
captain
anne ont
refusé
pour vous souhaiter à vous protéger de
votre femme notamment
épousé vous donc pas le choix
il faut que je me taise
c'est bon et sur 2 bail en même temps il
drague en sous-marin valérie girardi ne
leur aurait même proposé une rencontre à
trois
non mais c'est quoi cette histoire s'est
parlé dans les loges et on s'est dit
qu'on peut vraiment nous a proposé de
déjeuner mais déjeuner en tout bien tout
honneur les trois trophées 3 c'est le
code pour plan à trois
[Rires]
ans avec nos deux chiens je vois qu'il
ya des alliances quand même
abattu pas de proposer isabelle aussi l
été par
isabelle
composer le 06 oui mais elle est la
bienvenue et lisa ciel venir avec du
recul que j'oserais les quatre plaisir
du matin comme on s'est dit tous genres
du matin au medley merci merci